your CAD what'd you do today or what did
you do at school nothing how was it fine
you know you always hear that but if
parents can be intentional about how
they talk to to their kids after school
I always ask my kids and I we have a
running thing so every day after school
I say best worst and weirdest and so
they have to tell me their best thing
their worst thing and their weirdest
thing which ends up with a lot of funny
stories but it also gives us an
opportunity to kind of dive into ok so
something didn't go very well why not
what was the catalyst for that not going
well or if something went great what
kind of strategies did you use to pull
it off I mean how did you prepare how
did you study how did you handle that
tricky situation on the playground or
whatever but talking to your kids
instead of just you know good job
a on the test ask them like like how did
you prepare for this what kind of
learning went into this and and likewise
that they didn't do so well like let's
let's talk about what happened and so
really helping parents build that
communication with their kids about
strategies for for learning and and what
works and what doesn't and just and and
having them draw the the link between
effort and achievement is really
important so the kids are hearing it
everywhere they go I think the bottom
line to when it comes to parents is they
are sending us the most precious gift
they have and there is nothing worse of
a feeling than being a parent and seeing
your child struggle and reading or
struggle in math and you want so badly
to fix it for them but you don't know
how and so sometimes when these parents
come to us and they're frustrated and
they just want it fixed they're coming
from a place of love and we have to
train them too you know because they'll
come upset my child is not a good reader
or my child not go to med school now and
yet right so what are we gonna do you
know there really is if you really want
to see the kids just go far a strong
partnership between the kiddo the
teacher of the parents you know you've
got a big support system there to really
hold up and then it comes down to what
with beanie which I met earlier all
right we've got our support system
holding you now let's go for some
efforts right right exactly
it sounds like a really strong kind of
foundation when you have that that
sounds beautiful we have a question from
Alyssa B how would you recommend
facilitating and encouraging other
faculty to promote growth mindset so
this is a good question of like what do
you do kind of in your actual school
environment I think being transparent
and being vulnerable teachers work
really hard and we do not have a lot of
time in the day and it's you know
sometimes it's really easy to hear
something and think that's just another
thing mm-hmm so I think by being
transparent and allowing people to come
into your classroom or see see the
fruits of your kids labor let your kids
lead things you know let your kids be
the ones who go out and talk about
things because that's where that's where
the power lies and that's where you show
that these mountains are being moved and
then I think also being vulnerable being
able to go to a meeting and say guys I'm
really working on growth mindset but I
really feel like I personally am failing
here I need some help and having those
open discussions I think encourage more
people you know we talk about our
students feeling safe but it's the same
thing with the staff the teachers we've
got to feel safe too to kind of embark
on this because it's uncomfortable at
the beginning and it's a new way of
thinking and speaking and there's a big
power shift
Rea from the teacher to the kiddos and
that's nerve-racking at the beginning
but it it it's such a positive
powershift scared to take at the
beginning right getting administrators
and on it too I really believe it just
like people approach things with the
growth in fixed mindset the school has a
organizations have a growth or fixed
mindset and a lot of times you don't
have to look further than like the
handbook to figure out like what are we
valuing here are revaluing growth are
evaluating perfection and so getting a
good gauge on what is being valued and
how are only the kids who are getting on
a honor roll are they the ones that are
being celebrated do we have ways of
celebrating kids who are making less or
making incremental steps toward growth
like can we celebrate that at all in our
culture and so as a teacher I think you
have an opportunities feature admins and
say we need to refocus and and celebrate
and like Dave said this is evidence but
this is research-based there is a strong
body of research going back what thirty
or forty years data that that supports
this as a valuable learning intervention
and just sharing that and being you know
being an advocate for it in your school
I think is is key to changing the
culture of the entire school right yeah
the only thing I would add is just that
I mean I think the I when I've talked to
teachers who have we've kind of kind of
catalyzed these kinds of cultural
transformations of their schools I think
a lot of the times it's really happened
with just a handful of teachers who
really started doing it and they really
started modeling it and going and
talking to other teachers about it and
and and just you know it took it took
some time it wasn't like a we're all
gonna do growth mindset all at once I
think in my experience that usually
doesn't work very well it's usually more
that you you kind of you kind of start
around this kind of core crystal group
of teachers and then it kind of branches
off from there and as other teachers you
can see the kind of amazing things that
can happen and and then they start to
say hey maybe maybe that could work with
my class actually I'd like to stab my
kids be that inspired or that motivated
actually I'm very curious to know for
Sam what made you want to try out these
growth my inside activities like what
was the catalyst for that it actually
stemmed in the beginning it was I
noticed that my kiddos were coming
without tools and at the time I was in
fifth grade and I had to send you know
my babies off to middle school and I
wanted them as empowered and with as
many strategies as they could possibly
have before they went because middle
school can be really difficult years and
so I started looking at things like
their perseverance how do they speak to
one another how do they advocate for
themselves when they need something
and we started little by little looking
at things like that and I started really
kind of trying to research and find
things to support that and it's funny
you know
we watched beginning there I show my
kids a video of a really famous quantum
theorists who you know he's melded
science and math and he's not working on
the same equation now for 12 years and I
promised my kids I will never make you
work with an equation but if you can do
12 years we can do 20 minutes to like
build that stamina mm-hmm and then it
just kind of grew from there and it was
kind of the perfect timing you know
Annie's book came out Carol Dweck's book
coming out you know PERTs is really on
this stage now learn storms out and it
was just it feels like a lot of us were
seeking this right if you look at the
manifestation of what has really come to
the surface so I think a lot of teachers
at the same time really we're feeling
the same need right that's beautiful all
right I'm glad we can help fill that
need that makes me feel good
Leanne Morgan from Ontario asked are
there words and phrases that foster
growth that I can include in my student
conversations I think actually all of
you have touched upon this idea of
vocabulary so let's see if we can
that's on that I'm a firm advocate of
power of yet they have anytime they say
any kind of negative talk I'll point to
them yeah you know and then they have to
say it and then we're big on alright now
what or great what do you need we
practice a lot at the beginning of the
year building a toolkit up okay I'm
stuck now so what all right I can ask
for more time I can ask to hear it in a
different way I can ask the teacher to
rephrase it I can ask you know we we
talked about what are the different
things I can do to advocate for myself
because I I might not always be within
these four walls when I encounter a
problem and I need to have those
intrinsic skills and so having that that
vocabulary ready for your kids and then
on the teachers part really trying to
back away from good job that's right hmm
leave it to the class mathematicians
what do you think this mathematician has
proposed this idea thoughts you know and
at the beginning they just stare at you
like is it right or wrong you know but
they start to learn and it's so powerful
on it it's so hard as a teacher though
when somebody throws you know something
wildly incorrect up there but the cool
thing is is there's a lot of grace in
that too because when the kids start
debating it and discussing it we talked
about do you have the right to change
your mind
and the kid will say oh I'd like to
change my answer and I think there's so
much power in how kids speak to each
other and speaks themselves and then
it's it's hard for the teacher but kind
of backing up and just giving those
launch points those launching questions
right and then your your crowd control
at that point I think I'm just being
mindful of like person praise forces
process praise so if we say to a kid who
does really well like oh you're so smart
they equate doing well with being smart
that it's some some inherent inborn
thing that they have that they can do
well and then when inevitably they hit a
setback which it will and they don't do
so well then all of a sudden it's like a
question of like well if I'm not smart
than Who am I and so just being mindful
of praising effort and the process that
they took to learn like that was a
really great
do you use or like how you solve that
problem or if they breeze through
something maybe that wasn't challenging
enough let's try to find something else
so being mindful of that being more
robust with your feedback I think we
like to use stickers and say good job a
lot in the in the book I wrote we call
it live read it somewhere else but they
call it Paulo phrase so like on American
Idol
I think back to American Idol like the
first with Simon and Paula and Randy
first Paula would always say good job
and something was a lot meaner but he
was much more specific and so I don't
want to be be like that but definitely
be specific and the feedback that you're
giving and I would rather have less
feedback that's more specific than
generalized praise that that is really
meaningless so so you want to be be
mindful of that and then yeah I just
think thinking about that I used to say
come on you can do this it's so easy and
that was something I said as a teacher
and I look back and think oh my gosh you
know what that wasn't easy for that
person it wasn't easy for me or I
thought it was easy but it wasn't easy
for that person and so what I was saying
was actually not helping it was
counterproductive and I thought I was
being helpful and so just like really
being mindful of what you're saying and
how that that affects the student that
you're working with is really important
yeah I really love all those points yeah
I guess just from a growth mindset
standpoint I think the the kinds of
language we use is the kinds of words we
use it can be really important and and
there are so for example are you
referring to things as for example II
can talk about building skills like
really calling out when you're doing
something why are you doing it oh you're
you're building your skills you're
becoming a mathematician or you're
building or you're building your writing
skills right now you're you're becoming
a better writer or we're really really
focusing students on those processes and
kind of how the fact that they're
learning while while they're doing and
so it's a kind of taking again you know
taking the focus off of the end result
and really focusing it on the thing that
the students can actually control for
themselves what is the process that
they're doing and really reminding them
and kind of debriefing with them so that
they really understand what it is that
they're doing
and that all this effort they're doing
it's not just going into a gray it's
going into them leveling up done
becoming a writer then becoming a
mathematician or a scientist or whatever
that may be a great civic thinker
whatever that may be they're really
developing those skills and really
making sure to call out that that
learning is a process that they're
enacting in your class right so not just
like work so sake of work but work for
the sake of growth of growth and
betterment I love that all right so
we're gonna wrap up I'm going to
actually throw you a bit of a curveball
and ask you a final question but we're
the challenge so what is one last piece
of advice for teachers for fostering
growth mindset that you would give this
year if you can give it it in ten words
or less oh I know all right I'm going to
start with Dave have a growth mindset
about building a growth mindset culture
I would say model your growth and fixed
mindsets and normalized mistakes in your
classroom okay be vulnerable mm-hmm
be a champion for your kids and model I
love that that's very good and all very
tweetable very great so I want to thank
Dave and Annie and Sam for joining us
today
I learned something and I hope that you
all did too I want to remind everyone
that there's still some time to sign up
so if you haven't signed up please sign
up like right now today but definitely
by the end of October
and if you keep on tagging your
classroom celebrations with hashtag
learn storm on Twitter and Facebook we
really love seeing in the office so
please keep on doing that welcome back
to the school yours teachers thank you
and goodbye
you